while the Prime Minister of Malta Joseph
Muscat joins me now and Prime Minister I
wonder first of all could you tell us
what the impact this migrant problem of
people crossing from Africa is having on
your country well we are at the
crossroads of the busiest shipping route
in the world so usually this gives the
advantages since the Commerce is
striving obviously right now and over
the past decade or so we're in the
Justin bang in the middle of a crisis
we're handling it most of the time we're
handing it alone with our Italian
colleagues and finally it seems that the
world at least Europe is waking up to
acknowledge the reality that we are
facing and that this is not them just a
European that is not just a
Mediterranean problems it's not just an
Italian or Maltese problem this is
really a European problem and finally
yes we know all the long-term solutions
development and Africa international
development aid and all the rest that's
we know that but finally it seems that
there is a concrete result to give
backing to operations that are targeted
against the criminal networks that are
making millions out of these vessels but
what about dealing with the people who
are now crossing the sea to Malta I mean
how many people dead and alive any up on
your shores and what's happening to them
luckily enough the the way we are
coordinating these operations with the
Italians we are small countries most
member state of the European Union our
military assets are limited but hundred
percent of our military assets are
devoted to search and rescue operations
we're the only country in Europe to do
that and I believe one of the very few
and the world really to to do that so we
are managing to save many lives even the
the
the people who died last Saturday it
wasn't because of a failed rescue but
because of something which happened
during the rescue operation where a
vessel a merchant ship was trying to
rescue these peoples so right now we're
not experiencing the haunting images of
people being washed ashore dead but we
know that there are many people about
whom we don't know who sink even before
getting on our radar or on the European
radar really and as a member of the
European Union you are convinced now are
you that the the Alliance is about to
take action which is going to deal with
this problem no I believe it when I see
it
so if you you you intend or you'll be
referring to the 10-point plan most of
it is a rehash of previous statements to
say the truth the real news in all this
in my opinion is that finally Europe is
taking a proactive stand rather than a
reactive stand and not only advocating
the long term solutions or making
statements of intent on issues and we
all know that migration is a thorny
issue in each and every European Member
State it's obvious but apart from that
that there are there is finally the
resolve to take short term solutions
similar to the ones Europe took of the
coast of Somalia so of the coast of
Somalia there was there is a problem of
piracy but the problem was greed tackled
in effective manner because Europe
wasn't saying look we'll let the pirates
board the ships and then maybe we'll do
something no there's a mission in the
Atlanta mission that by means of
European coordination prevents pirates
from boarding ships and it's a
deterrence the same way there is a
proposal and we're counting on together
with our Italian colleagues who I I
heard with my parents who were together
in Rome yesterday and we heard on the
phone Prime Minister Cameron we heard
Francois Hollande angle America
the institutions to the European
institutions what we're looking at is a
situation where Europe gives its backing
to those member states who have the
military capability more that doesn't
have the military capability to not to
invade Libya for goodness sake but to
make targeted strikes and actions
against the criminal networks that are
netting millions out of this so the
vessel that capsized on Saturday if the
estimate of around 100 persons is is
correct those people those traffickers
or criminals who organized this voyage
out of just one voice netted anything
between one and five million euros just
from one voyage of debt so you can
imagine this is an industry a
large-scale criminal industry that needs
to be treated as such in Sudan of course
there were military our military Task
Force will send out a naval task force
and they were patrols off the coast of
saddam lee is that what you'd like to
see naval patrols by EU nations along
the coast of Libya no I think that if
one looks at the proposal of a naval
blockade I understand the the rationale
behind a naval blockade between and
through leave it's done in international
waters it might end up being a pull
factor rather than a deterrent to the to
the to the criminal organizations
because rather than them trying to get
people to Italy or to Malta just taking
people to the ships and then there would
be the international duty to do a number
of things what and that the proposal is
all about and obviously there are plans
and what sort of plans would they be if
they are disclosed to the like that but
there are obviously plans by technical
people at aiming at making sure that the
criminal networks so right now one of
the things we're experiencing is that
when we're rescuing people at sea there
were at least one or two incidents
reported over the past
few weeks where these criminals shoot at
the Italian Coast Guard say because they
want the boat back that means that there
is a shortage of boats such was the the
influx of immigrants over the past a few
months one of the aims is to make sure
that these boats don't get to Libya and
they don't have enough capacity to
transfer people that will save lives
from being lost at sea because most of
the well many of the people we speak to
tell us it might be the first time they
see the sea in their life they don't
know how to swim so it's obvious that so
many lives are lost at sea
obviously that's only a short-term
solution and it's not the only solution
the long-term solution is international
development aid is the democratization
of countries in Africa and most
definitely is the securitization of
Libya and that's where we play a role as
a small country which is very near to
Libya culturally and geographically we
try to get as many tribes as possible
together in order for them to get around
having a national unity government or a
semblance of national Nutini unity
government in order then for them to ask
if necessary international help to
securitize the country prime minister
Joseph Muscat of Malta thank you very
much indeed for joining us